going back to australia though one thing
i did notice
uh hanging out with australians is that
australian sarcasm is just on a level
that i've never seen before okay
because how sir because here's the thing
it's like you guys are constantly
looking for the next target to prank and
you never talk about this verbally but
as soon as you say as soon as someone
makes up a lie or jokes about someone or
about something to a foreigner or
something everyone just
everyone in australia universally agrees
to get in on this joke oh yeah yeah
right and that's why like one thing i
didn't understand before going to
australia is like why every australian
just agreed to try to trick the world
about drop bears yeah which uh what what
is like the drop bear law what do you
mean trick they're they're real
this guy this guy
right there he they pretend like people
live in australia
yeah right live in a [ __ ] day
no one lives there it's a simulation so
when i saw this happening first hand
yeah it was uh we did a stream in
australia where
like we found out what tim tam slams
were
yeah that was my favorite thing we found
out what happened uh we found out what
team time slams were so tim tam slams uh
so tim tams are kind of biscuits in
australia yeah like a chocolate biscuit
yeah it's like two uh two biscuits with
like a chocolate filling and what
happens is you bite you bite off two
corners yep and you put it in tea or
coffee or whatever and then you suck out
the uh liquids literally no point in
doing this yeah absolutely there's no
benefit to either the drink i think i
think you have to know how to do it in
order to get a visa yeah australia but
um yeah it's definitely on the
citizenship test that's for sure but we
did it because they're you know because
we're on the australia set and the the
live stream we did was australia theme
so they were like oh let's just get the
boys to do a team team slam exactly
completely failed at it yeah um but one
person who wasn't there was sydney
and we were we had a panel together
where
someone asked us on stage if we'd done a
tim tam slam and obviously me and me and
connor had just done one so we said yes
and sydney's like what's a tim tam slam
and for some reason as soon as she said
that everyone every australian perked up
and i was just like this is this is
content right here this is content right
here and then so joey jokingly says okay
so what happens in australia when you
get a pack of tim tams is you just slam
it on the floor and you just [ __ ]
slam it uh until it's [ __ ] until it's
crumbs and you eat the crumbs and that's
the tim tam yeah right and then you know
and
you know uh the crowd and the the mc
we're all just like yeah
yeah that's he's right and the thing is
i
me being british i was like they said
that so sarcastically yeah of course
sydney's never gonna fall for that so in
my mind i was like i thought sydney got
the joke yeah i thought sydney had
gotten the joke
and so
after this the next day we all had a
signing together
and someone in sydney signings
brings her a pack of tim tams
and then
and then she go and then he goes oh do
you mind doing a tim tam slam for me
and sydney goes you know of course of
course i'll do a ten time i know what
that is so i'm sitting necessarily just
signing away and all i hear next to me
is just
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] cindy
what are you doing what are you doing
sydney she's just like i'm doing my
tim's have slept why are you stopping me
why are you stopping me i'm like sitting
there
they've tricked you
as soon as i said that everyone every i
swear every [ __ ] australian everyone
in the queue looked at me and i was like
god what are you doing what are you
doing guys why would you say that and i
was just like how how have you all just
agreed to just like try to trick
everyone that you've everyone that
you've met were they just was everyone's
gonna watch her batter these biscuits
absolutely i was going to she was
battering it for like a good few seconds
and nobody said [ __ ]
everyone was my brother was just like
yep you got it got it just keep doing a
couple of times you're going to be
watching being like you got this queen
all right next step you just got to pick
the crumbs up and eat it and i was just
like
it was so funny i was impressed oh my
god that the australia chose one of
those boring [ __ ] food items to be
like their mascot like it's literally
just a chocolate biscuit
and it's a very very ordinary chocolate
tasting biscuit like you guys can't talk
you you guys are like yes
chips and a fried fish listen the uk is
not any better right but i expected
better from australia because you had a
do-over you got to do it right and you
were like oh let's just get the generic
ass chocolate biscuit which we have we
have 10 times in the uk they're just
called [ __ ] normal chocolate biscuits
like we have the exact same type of
biscuits we just don't care because
they're nothing special but australia
decided oh this is going to be our thing
and you go to the airport and
everything's tim tam themed in the gift
section like this is [ __ ] yeah no
it's because it's it's because it's the
most uh non-challenging food item that
any foreigner from any country can be
like yes that's good that's acceptable i
like chocolate i like biscuits right
like it's kind of difficult to be like
you know oh so australia we have this
thing called vegemite and we have this
part
it's good and we have this party food
called fairy bread uh favorite [ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly right it's good
it's two opposites right veggie might
[ __ ]
two opposites right here but i think
anyone of any palette can agree that
like yeah [ __ ] who doesn't like
chocolate biscuits i don't like drinking
biscuits well that's a you problem
everyone else everyone else likes
chocolate biscuits so that's why we used
it as like a marketing method as a kid i
like chocolate tasting stuff and then
you know what happened as i got older i
just felt that chocolate tasting things
just taste bad and like really
artificial almost i don't know why
even though it's not like a lot of times
melt chocolate in it or just put
chocolate i don't know why i mean like i
i'll admit that i don't eat as much
chocolate as i used to definitely i
can't eat as much chocolate just like
physically because i start to get sick
but like i'm not very sickly i want to
go as far as to say that i will just
pass up chocolate at any chance i can
get like normal chocolate like chocolate
bars
i'm there but like chocolate flavored
things it'll be really sickly am i i
don't know
personally i don't know i've given the
chance i can i can i can slam a package
on connor's food
he said that i'm just like